you've been thinking long and hard about
where to study abroad join us in Europe
the most popular destination for
studying if you need to know how it
works and how one should go about it
turn to study in Europe under the
countries section you can easily find
information about each destination turn
to national portals for gathering
information about study programmes
lookup universities their programs and
admission requirements you can also read
experiences from several alumni this way
you know exactly what to expect
you may be looking for a scholarship to
fund your studies click planning your
studies to find funding opportunities
including the erasmus+ program and other
programs funded by the EU and don't
forget about scholarships offered by the
country you're from or going to or
provided by individual institutions
don't leave any stone unturned
now knowing your options qualifications
and funding opportunities take the
knowledge you have and put it into use
apply to the European University that
suits you best be in time and remember
to provide everything required when
you're admitted and accept the offer
arrange your visa health insurance and
accommodation now all that is left is to
pack a suitcase your family might have
great tips on how to pack and when you
get there enjoy your study in Europe
experience
[Music]
you